hello everyone and welcome to a really
cool game that was played yesterday in
the pro chess league and now I was just
browsing the internet as I usually do
and I came across a tweet by the protest
League they said that this is the worst
position in in the history of chess so I
of course was very interested in this
position and the game that well that
resulted in this position so here it is
I do hope you enjoy it let's check it
out
Geary now plays against a lot in
Grandmaster and Nikita medicos and it's
well it's quite the game so let's check
it out
give reopens with b4 we have Knight to
f6 c4 e6 and now waiting to see if a
Knight to c3 will be played had to go
maybe for the nimzo-indian or in this
case Knight to f3 by Geary the antonyms
Oh which kinda kinda asks the black what
do you want to do here do you want to
continue d5 do you want to go for b6
something that was played in this game
which transposes into the queen's indian
defense and well the game does kind of
remind of the of the alpha zero versus
doctors games in in between queen's
indian defense openings but you'll see
what I mean
g3 gierek prepares the counter blacks
light-square bishop i think carrying his
own bishop with the ship to b7 bishop to
g2 and now Bishop to b4 with check
bishop to d2 blocking and now most most
often played moves are just bit of
characters or Bishop to e7 but here we
have a 5 by mesh cooks which defends the
bishop and although the white can
capture and miss a black's pawn
structure black gets a semi-open fall
for his rook so not really something
white white and brag about
we have castles by Gary we have castles
in the bishop to f4 this is a strongest
consider strongest in in theory
push it back to East 7 and now Queen to
c2 so both of them still in protected
waters of theory now Queen to c2
fighting for e4 at some point you might
want to play rook e1 or maybe move the
knight get that efore in so bishop back
to e4 pushing the Queen back Queen C 1
and now Russia back to b7 asking maybe
maybe Gary's interested in a nice draw
by repetition after Queen Queen back to
C to Bishop before but this one game
where Gary is not interested in a draw
he goes for Knight to c3 a continuous
development with Knight to e4 now which
is often what you want to do when you
have a bishop on b7 in the the Queen's
Indian defense the the nimzo-indian
defense and well similar defenses when
you have our light square bishop in
Cairo
and now Knight to b5 going after the c7
pawn we have c6 now pushing the knight
back and now Knight back to c3 Knight to
c7 although it looks very strong after
rook to e7 it doesn't really do all that
much yes you have a knight here but at
some point something like d6 can be
played and well you're just gonna have
to say that that Knight is terribly
misplaced and that there's no good way
to actually continue this for white you
could go for some d5 ideas but Indian
black will come out on top
so after c6 Knight back to c3 we've
captured some c3 Gary recaptures and now
d6 and this is a new move in the game
the in in the position there is a game
where defy was played younggu versus
vidit in was play deal last year the
game ended in a draw but here d6 is a
new move so already as of move 14 we
have a completely new game so let's see
what happens
Gary finally gets his efore move in we
have Knight to d7 and now rook a to d1
preparing to meet Knight of 6 would e5
which would which would be very strong
and even though you could go for 94
attack the Queen Queen c2 and now d5
white should why should definitely be
better here as at some point black will
have to make a breakthrough with your f6
or a5 he's gonna have a weak east
exponent and white white should be able
to to take advantage of that but it is
playable but black and still goes b5 and
giver replies with c5 he still wants to
open up the center as his rook is nicely
aligned with the Queen so black closes
the center but first Knight to f6 going
after the e4 pawn
Gary defense at Queen to c2 and only now
d5 closing this
Center with E 5 further closing the
center and nights the e8 and now it's
always a question who benefits more from
the closed center but I can tell you who
doesn't benefit this LightSquared Bishop
here that's a that's a pretty bad piece
and ok at some point B 4 will be played
maybe you can activate the bishop via
the a6 square but we'll see H for Geary
grabs more space on the kingside he
prepares to further push and now this
really does resemble of the of the alpha
0 versus doctors games where this light
square bishop really didn't didn't
participate in the game all that much we
have before black of course wants to
activate the bishop right away and now
Knight to g5 already threatening mate
asking black to further weaken his King
side so G 600 or you could capture but
mesh cops to decide decides that g6 is
better for now Knight back to f3 as the
knight no longer has any use there and
Bishop to e6 now at developing the
bishop attacking the rook rook F e1 and
now Knight to g7 the knight can now come
to either f5 or h5 but Gary doesn't
allow it bish of the h6 now the knight
cannot move as the rook would Hank so we
have looked a 7 and now comes Queen to
d2 just Rema nuvaring some pieces rook
to e8 now the knife can finally move but
now g4 it's a it's an excellent move
Gary found grabs more space and doesn't
allow the night to jump to f5 and also
it comes with a pawn sacrifice is if
black is willing to capture it however
grabbing this with just result in a
quick death for black for example
captures captures and Queen to f4 and
now you can see that this rook is coming
to III then to h3 and then well yeah
it's just very easy to play for example
you can capture here go Queen h6 check
after an a on h7 and so on so g4
brilliant moved by giri which prevents
the knight from entering the game but
also the pawn is poisonous so better
back the c8 bye-bye black and now Bishop
to h3 we have King tha
preparing to bring drew up the g8 and
now Russia back to g5 again asking are
you may be interested in some trade so I
can get my Knights the g5 which would
pressure the f7 pawn maybe I can get the
Queen to f4 pileup on the f7 pawn black
is not interested mesh crops goes for
rook to g8 but now Queen f4 as the f7
point is now week
well maybe not week but definitely
undefended
so Queen to f8 defending and now Bishop
the f6 Giri slowly by slowly you know
squeezes the physician we have worked a
b7 and now Bishop back to f1 at the
support with with the attack on the
Queen side that is coming Geary wants to
play a3 bust open the position here and
maybe get some looks into the game this
way so Bishop captures an f6 for the
lack of a better move with it captures
and f6 pushing the knight AG once again
back to e 8 and now Knight to e5 and now
this is an excellent square for the
knight and well it's hard to say where
where blacks position is gonna terior it
but there are a lot of ideas we have
worked the c7 as the c6 bone is under
attack
well was under attack and now g5 with
Bishop back to b7 now again adding
another defender here but this Bishop
just is having the worst day with a3
finally Gary's ready to bust open the
position here and bring the rooks into
the game and we have better back to a 8a
capture son before a cat person before
and now rook the a1 threatening to just
win the bishop so Russia back the b7 but
now rook the a7 you double approves this
way this rope is coming to a 1 now we h5
asking and maybe you're interested in
capturing on pass on I didn't get then I
can get king - h7 and I no longer have
to worry about the Kings side but Gary
says there's no need for that just I
just continue with my plan rook 81 King
to h7 by mesh coughs and now rook a for
going after the pawn here it's not much
you can do to defend the pawn you can
play b3 but now just rook the b 4 with a
double attack on the pawn and the bishop
so Bishop to c8 offering a rook trade
but of course gear is not interested in
trading he wants to further well I get
get the most out of the position so rook
the aad is now preparing to bring the
other rook to b8 we have worked the h8
wasting a move there's not much to do
here and also black is extremely low on
time here we have rugby to b8 and here
we have pretty much the D mortal - swung
there there is nothing to be done here
you cannot move anything rope captures
and see it is coming and there really is
no move you can play I mean you could
try and waste a move but doesn't really
do anything just captures and your only
attempt maybe at not losing material is
bishop here for some reason to try and
guard the knight this way but a lot of
moves win here for white so just for
example rook here next move you're gonna
pick up the bishop and there's nothing
you can do here so after this rugby to
b8 rook the b7 was played for some
reason as Black was extremely low on
time few seconds on the clock Gary just
the gobble up the bishop here with rook
captures on c8 and it was in this
position that nikita met officer
resigned the game and this beautiful
beautiful positional masterpiece was
created by Gary so yeah that's that's
the game like I said really remind you
of the the Queen's Indian defense alpha0
played against stockfish wherever
stalkerish really struggled couldn't get
anything into play and indian like here
that bishop really did not think in the
end it just disappeared but it's it's
really hard and it really makes you
think should you should you play this
Queen's Indian defense idea as well
maybe it can be played but after all
that alpha0 stockfish you know the games
it just seems like every every Queen's
Indian defense game I see ends up in
black just being completely destroyed
but yeah that's that's the position the
worst position in chess history I'm sure
there are a few that you know could
compete with it for for the number one
spot but as as the process like tweeted
it like this I decided to leave
as a title so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank thank
David Gill as Stephen White Stephen Beck
amid unum and Jeff graves for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to cover the Paul
Morphy saga continued need to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and you
know whatever else happens in the chest
world such as this game with the worst
chess position ever and also a question
for the end what do you think of Gary's
chances in the candidates tournament
that is well coming very soon in in 12
days it starts yeah thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day